hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the 1857 first
American chess congress in a third game
in their match theater littenheim versus
Paul Charles Murphy
now this is actually the fourth game
we've seen between well we're gonna see
between the two of them but only two of
them so far were from the actual
American chess congress tournament so
let's see what happens in this one like
I said it's the best of five
so if Murphy wins this one he wins yet
another match three to zero first he
defeated Thompson three to zero then he
defeated judge meat three to zero and
now he's leading two to zero against
least in Heinz so let's see if he can do
something about it so for this game he
brought something different to the party
instead of his usual stuff he went for
d4 as well he simply cannot afford
another loss so he's gonna try and play
a different type of game against Murphy
and I'm gonna open up the position which
kind of makes sense when you play
against Paul Murphy Murphy replies with
the d5 we have c4 e6 9th to c3 NDS
Knight to f6 in the first American chess
congress in game 3 between Lisa and hey
Lynn Murphy we have the Queens gambit
declined with Knight to f3 and c5 Morphy
goes for the scimitar with III Knight to
c6 by Murphy in now a three preparing
after this Bishop is developed which was
played in those names you can you can
play some like D captures on c5 and the
win win some Tempe here and it is still
the most popular move to play today
and here a six can be played it's it's a
new move like capture sore captures is a
popular move in this position but morph
is Bishop to d6 and not so much and and
for good reasons as you'll see we have d
characters on c5 as planned Bishop
captures and b4 now listen I waited for
more fee of course to develop his dark
square bishop and only then he made it
move again the Shabak d6 and now Bishop
to b2 and here we have castles buy more
flee now this position is still being
played even today in 2006 for example
Anton core above defeated Vladimir
spoken with c5 here in this position
Morphy her place tonight the b5 and it
is a move that after this game Layton
Hina versus Murphy was never reached
again so Murphy could go for better back
to be hit but then it's kind of I guess
he he he was thinking maybe if a six I
could go back the night I would still
have to bring back the Bishop to be able
to develop my work so instead more if he
goes Bishop to e7 REE maneuvering the
knight Knight B to D for now
an excellent square for the knight and
now Knights the e for more fear e
maneuvers his knight to the center of
the board with Knight captures on c6 b
captures and c6 and now Bishop to d3 so
lifts and I'm doing very good work in
this game his bishops are beautifully
placed here aimed at Morpheus King he's
gonna Castle maybe not right right away
maybe he's gonna go for something like
age 495 maybe try and open up BH file
maybe even at the price of a pawn all
depending on what more if he plays well
Murphy decides that he doesn't enjoy his
weak pawn and c6 and he probably wants
this diagonal for his Bishop so he gets
rid of it with c5 with night the d2 now
preparing to win upon on e4 and here
more if you could go for blush up to b7
but first he decides the trade Knight
characters Queen captures and now well
it's a it's hard to decide what to do
here here more if he has a chance to win
a pawn but for some reason he decided
not to do it for example C capture Sun
before and now if you continue with the
with the trade it captures a capture of
silver Bishop captures and Queen
captures with check after King captures
Bishop picks up the b4 pawn with check
and you have this past a pond which you
can push for some reason more if he
didn't enjoy this maybe he thought maybe
after after this maybe why doesn't have
to recap from a big white can play
something like
c5 and then instead of these two points
we can have something like captures and
captures and then okay you don't have a
past a pawn but you still went upon so
so maybe maybe maybe it was the way to
go but morphe had a different idea
he played d captures in c4 bishop not
captures but rather blush of efore now
going after more fees rook and here
morphe traits Queens with Queen captures
and e2 with check King captures
now getting the rock out of harm's way
rook to b8 but now listen high with his
Bishop air is about her ass more fees
rook a lot
look the b5 and now Bishop to c6
attacking the rook again Bishop to b6
and now b5 defending the bishop here in
threatening Bishop to c7 to trap the
rogue but morphine morphine's a very
nice idea
Bishop to b7 and now Lincoln has to be
very careful if he goes for the greedy
Bishop to c7 it's not the best move in
the position best is actually instead of
this move to just go Bishop captures on
b7 and after root characters solidify
with a 4 then you can bring the other
look into the game you can create a
passed pawn here the bishop already
guarding the the queening square so in
in the long run this would have been the
way to go but instead Olivia and played
the Bishop to c7 a bit prematurely and
now he allowed Murphy a certain idea
which you're more than welcome to pause
the video and try to find it while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting the doubled
pawn and that it needs to be pushed and
for those of you who just won't enjoy
the show it's c3 checked this is what
morphe played and it it really
complicates matters because of course if
you capture then Bishop to f6 check put
your put your king in the line of fire
but it's even worse if you don't capture
let's say King c2 then you get Bishop
captures and c6 and now if of course the
rook is captured you have this Bishop a4
check and now you grab another piece and
still if if you capture this then you
pick up the rook and if you don't then
it is just an incredibly strong passed
pawn so lift and hind played the best
movie played King captures on c3
Bishop to see sorry Bishop captures on
c6 first we have Bishop captures and b6
eliminating more Facebook and now push
up the f6 wait check we are king back to
d2 and now a captures on b6 with B
captures and c6 and only now Bishop
captures on a one route captures anyone
and now rook the see it going after this
pawn here so the material is equal but
morphe will
win the C pawn with a for preparing a 5
to create further weaknesses and now
more if you want for rook captures on c6
and we have a 5 and here the problem is
you cannot play b5 to create two
connected passed pawns because a 6 is
deadly here because if you go back Roxi
8 we have looked the a 5 now going going
after the the points here and you don't
really have a good reply here because
even if for example okayed you can still
capture it and black cannot capture
because of a background can mate and
even if you play something like b4 still
a 7 look here and again rook the b5 and
there is no defense against rook to b8
because if you capture of course is just
made and if you don't if you make some
breathing room for a king then just
check and pick up the roof because if
you trade of course the White gets a
queen into the game so after this
a5 idea morphe had a cap for an a5 we
have rook captures an a5 and now g6 of
course more he has to waste a move to
get rid of his background quickness is
with f3 and now rook the beasts
explained my morphe offering of his
offering up his c5 pawn respecting
lifting littenheim enough that he
acknowledges that this position is a
draw so listen I simply captured that
morphe plate looked a bit to check and
it was in this position of course that
the two of them agreed to a draw because
after the rug blocks you have an endgame
with 4 points on the King side each this
is there's no point in playing this even
though ok morphe might have you know if
you want to drag this out for like
another 6 hours maybe he could have he
could have continued playing this game
instead of maybe this rook to b6 idea
maybe started bringing the King into the
game and so on but you know morphe
decided that that he's now two and a
half to half and he only needs a half a
point to win the match so he's happy
with a draw here with the black pieces
but yeah I'm sure it's something you
haven't expected I'm sure you maybe some
of you thought that morphe we're just
gonna obliterate everyone 3 to 0 but it
is not the case so you can tell your
friends you know at the bar and the
library that the first person at the
Dodge
a loss against Paul Morphy in the first
American just Congress in 1857 was good
old Theodore littenheim here who scored
his first draw against Murphy something
no no one achieved here just yet
yeah that's game three of their match
like I said two and a half to half in
Murphy's favor so the match continues
first match to go you know further than
three games so it's gonna be very
interesting to see what happens I would
like to thank James McNamara Pat Carbone
Pollock slow-mo James Abraham and Ryan
Schneider for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon of
course continuing the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world like the candidates
tournament that starts in about a week
yeah I think y'all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day